he is revered as one of the greatest
artists of all time for centuries his
typifies the perfect artistic genius his
greatest legacy is the surviving works
that we can see today the Sistine Chapel
the Statue of David yet behind the
artworks lies a complex and stubborn man
and in this week's by graphics we go
beyond the facade to discover the real
Michelangelo
[Music]
easily in the 15th century was very
different to the country that we know
today back then it was a collection of
small republics these city-states were
all lands of the governorship of the
Pope who was located in Rome the key
republics were Florence Genoa and Venice
every state had its own governor's its
own nobles peasants priests and
government officials nestled in the
remote Apennine mountains of central
Italy was the small village of Capri see
it was here on March the 6th 1475 the
franceska de neri boone arathi gave
birth to her second son Michelangelo
her husband's lot of each see de
Leonardo we are naughty Simoni was a
lowly official who had the job of
convicting and sentencing criminals when
baby Michelangelo was six months old the
family of four moved to Florence here
are a lot of heat so bought a small farm
near the village of Settignano it was in
this village that the child spent his
early years under the care of a wet
nurse farming off newborns to a wet
nurse for the first two years of life
was a common practice at that time the
woman who took in Michelangelo was
married to a stonecutter in later years
when he had transformed himself into a
sculptor Michelangelo commented that he
had drunk marble dust with his nurses
milk when he was three Michelangelo
returned to live with his family in
Florence the family was poor Rams with
new babies arriving frequently the
household was overcrowded
Lodovico received a meager government
salary and his farm wasn't very
successful in fact he believed that the
work of a lowly farmer was beneath him
when he was six years of age young
Michelangelo's tough life got even
tougher his mother died leaving behind
five young sons including a newborn
Ludovico did his best working two jobs
and still managing to trundle the boys
after Mass at the Church of Santa Croce
in Florence every Sunday this church was
filled with magnificent works of art
including a crucifix carved by the
famous sculptor Donatello and wall
paintings by he also one of the greatest
artists of all time
the young Michelangelo must have
marveled at these magnificent pieces in
1485 not a Vico took a new wife Lucrezia
degli who Baldini gagliano came from a
rich family bringing six hundred Florin
to the union as a dowry this was an
enormous amount at the time and it flips
the fortunes of the family overnight an
immediate result of the family's
newfound wealth was the blood of the Eco
was able to afford to send Michelangelo
to a Latin school to learn reading
writing and mathematics but the boy soon
proved that he was no academic bored
with his lessons he would stare out of
the window while doodling on paper
however one thing he did fall in love
with was poetry
[Music]
returning home for vacation Michael
Angelli told his father that he was more
interested in art than in academic
studies but Lada Vico was not impressed
at that time artists were the lowly paid
servants of noblemen being considered
little more than a servant
Lodovico wanted his son to aspire to
more than that the only person who
seemed to understand Michelangelo's
passion for art was an older boy that he
had befriended by the name of Francisco
granite see Francisco himself was a
budding artists apprentice to the famous
artist Domenico Ghirlandaio he took
Michelangelo to his master's workshop
and showed him works in progress
the younger boy was mesmerised by what
he saw he knew that being an artist was
his destiny despite his father's
negativity Michelangelo kept begging to
be allowed to pursue his passion
meanwhile his friend Francisco
encouraged him to produce some drawings
which he showed to his master galleon
Dyer the great artist was impressed and
expressed the desire to also take
Michelangelo on as an apprentice finally
lots of hiko relented and at the age of
12 his son became apprentice to Galan
Dyer the master and the most successful
artists workshop in Florence along with
his two brothers they were kept busy
decorating churches in Florence the
brothers had a number of apprentices
aged between 8 and 15 who lived with
them and assisted with paintings and
murals the parents including Lodovico
had to pay for living expenses and for
training from the Ghirlandaio brothers
young Michelangelo learns how to prepare
a wooden panel for painting and how to
plaster a wall in preparation for the
painting of a fresco he was also taught
how to make working drawings called
cartoons which would form the basis of
finished paintings
[Music]
among the apprentices Michelangelo was
an immediate standout still he proved to
be stubborn and quite full of himself he
was given the task of copying works
previously drawn by his master and
having done so declared that his works
were better than the originals Galan's I
acknowledged that the boy had great
talent
but he was angered by his prideful
attitude he also saw that Michelangelo
lacked the patients needed to learn some
of the skills required such as painting
frescoes he showed little interest in
grinding and mixing paints and couldn't
be bothered mixing the ingredients
needed for the smooth plaster needed for
fresco painting when he was 14
Michelangelo went one step too far he
had copied some drawings that his master
had done of women but then he dared to
correct some finer aspects of the
originals by going over them with a
broad nib pen this was too much
Galileo kicked Michelangelo out of the
workshop claiming that there was no
teaching this know-it-all rather than
being discouraged the talented teen made
the decision that paint and plaster went
off for him he considered them to be a
lesser form of art to him the real skill
lay in stone producing fine sculptures
of the human form this desire would take
him to the very pinnacle of Florentine
nobility the house of Medici
[Music]
before Michelangelo had been dismissed
by Ghirlandaio
some members of the ruling medici family
visited the workshop among them was an
elderly sculptor named Burt Aldo de
Giovanni this man noticed the talent
that Michelangelo possessed and struck
up a relationship with the boy after his
dismissal the budding young sculptor
sought out the old man but Aldo was
employed by Lorenzo de Medici the most
powerful man in the city he was making
statues medals for the man and looking
after is our collection many of Lorenzo
statues were displayed in a garden where
artists went to draw and carve this area
was a gathering place for the students
sculptors who would get feedback and
instruction from bertoldo about their
work soon Michelangelo was a regular in
the garden the now fifteen-year-old
began creating sculptures from clay and
bringing them to the garden though he
was younger than the other budding
sculptors his skill was clearly beyond
this this led to jealousy sometimes it
even led to physical violence in one
encounter Michelangelo even had his nose
broken but the boy he was not deterred
begging a piece of marble from another
sculptor he created his first relief
carving the head of a faun just as he
had been hoping this sculpture was seen
by lauren zima DC who was immediately
taken with the boys skill he brought
Michelangelo into his fault giving him
his own room and paying him an allowance
the young artists life was now more
peaceful he was able to settle down to
the task of perfecting his chosen art
form one of his first major projects was
to carve a scene from mythology on
marble as a relief panel this was the
Battle of the Centaurs these creatures
with the heads and arms of men the
bodies of horses gave him plenty of
scope to show action and form the
realism and gentle precision of this
work is remarkable for a sculptor of
such a young age the other major piece
that Michelangelo produced while working
in the house of Medici was a relief
panel called Madonna of the steppes
it shows the Virgin Mary nursing the
infant Jesus the piece is carved on fine
white marble and shows the Madonna's
face in profile as she holds her infant
son against her things
whirring remarkably well for the 17
year-old he was living in the inner
sanctum of the richest family in the
city and he had a powerful patron who
admired his talents unfortunately it
wasn't a last in April 1492 Lorenzo
suddenly
his son Pierrot took over but he kept
little for sculpture
he gave Michelangelo no work until the
winter when he decided that he would
like a snowman made he ordered
Michelangelo to make one it would prove
to be the artists strangest Commission
around the same time the prior of Santo
Spirito
asked the young sculptor to make a
crucifix for his church delighted with
the result of the prior gave
Michelangelo the use of a room in which
he could work here he was able to
dissect corpses in order to study
Anatomy the idea behind this was of
course to make the most lifelike
sculptures of the human body possible he
believed that in order to know how to
make these sculptures he had to know how
the human body was put together thus he
actually became one of the first people
do dissect and study the human body in
this way
[Music]
by 1494 Florence was facing a crisis an
army led by King Charles the eighth of
France was at the walls and was
threatening to overrun the city many
people including Michelangelo fled the
city he travelled to Bologna in northern
Italy and then on to Venice an important
trading city here Michelangelo he hoped
to find work however he could not find
any employment so he went back to
Melania having lost his patron
Michelangelo set out in search of a
replacement he found it in the form of
Gian Francesco Algar Vande a local noble
and politician aldra Vandy set his
talented new sculptor to the task of
carving the missing figures at the
unfinished shrine of San Domenico in the
Church of the same name again
Michelangelo now 20 had fallen on his
feet he enjoyed a comfortable home had
stone and supplies provided and received
commissions for its art work just as it
happens in Florence this bread
resentment among other sculptors they
paid rents brought tools and stone and
survived out of their own pockets
[Music]
meanwhile back in Florence a change of
power had occurred a priest by the name
of Jeolla more Savonarola had instigated
a fierce campaign against the house of
Medici when the threat of French
invasion heard emerged the house of
Medici had fled the city leaving
Savonarola free to take power this
strict churchmen disapproved of
paintings and sculptors that showed the
naked human body as a result prospects
were not good for local sculptors
however in 1495 Michelangelo felt a
great urge to return to Florence to see
his family while then he made contact
with some members of the house of Medici
now living under false names one of them
lorenzo de pierre francesco de medici
wanted Michelangelo to help him sell a
statue that he had made earlier it was a
figure of the Roman god of love cubit if
the statue was aged to look like an
ancient statue Lorenzo reasoned it would
make a lot of money in Rome Michelangelo
smeared the statue with dirt to make it
look as if it had been buried he then
took the forged antique to Rome where it
was purchased by a senior churchmen
Cardinal Riario while in Rome
Michelangelo was introduced to some
powerful people including members of the
border family who numbered among them
the Pope Cardinal Riario who is well
aware that Michelangelo was really the
creator of kuipers quickly commissioned
him to create another statue for his
collection the statue that resulted has
come to be recognized as Michelangelo's
first masterpiece the statue of Bacchus
the Greek god of wine and celebrations
yes although everyone else was impressed
the Cardinal was not he thought the gods
looked too drunk and refused to pay for
the work Michelangelo now had to fight
to get paid for a job that he had
already completed on top of this he
received news that his father had fallen
into bad financial straits what he
needed and fast was a new patron to
support not just himself but also his
family
[Music]
for several months nothing seemed to pan
out for the 21 year old master sculptor
he was without a patron he was without
payment for his Bacchus statue and his
father was in desperate need of
financial assistance then in November of
1497 things took a turn for the better
he was commissioned to produce an
exciting new work by a French ambassador
by the name of cardinal jean bill had
Tula growler
the Cardinal envisioned a statue of the
Virgin Mary cradling the dead Jesus a
subject known as the Pieta it took
michelangelo two years to complete the
Pieta but it was worth it the finished
work was displayed in the Vatican and
everyone who saw it was amazed at the
realism of the flesh and fabric that the
sculptor had fashioned from the cold
model the Pieta made michelangelo famous
now the most powerful men in Europe were
clamoring to have him work for them it
seemed as if his money woes were finally
behind him
[Music]
back in Florence the scene had changed
once again Savonarola the priest had
fallen into disfavor and it's been
executed it was now safe for artists to
return and pursue projects there the
authorities of the Florentine Cathedral
began to formulates the idea to
Commission a giant statue of the
biblical killer of Goliath young David
the two sculptors had already been
commissioned to do the job
both had failed merely managing to make
the huge block of marble almost unusable
in 1501 the job was given to
Michelangelo in order to do the job the
sculptor had to stop working on another
job in Romans relocate to Florence this
flitting from one project to another
became a common practice and one that
created frequent legal ramifications the
creation of David was an immensely
challenging and lengthy job the first
decision was to choose a pose that
fitted in with the way the marble had
already been worked this prevented him
from emulating the traditional pose
which showed David standing with
Goliath's head at his feet so therefore
he decided to depict David in the
moments before the fight as if it was
looking upon his foe his next move was
to surround the huge piece of marble
with barricades then he went to work he
tirelessly chipped away at the giant
three years later the Statue of David
was completed it was a triumph
with crowds lavishing praise on the
creator of the 14-foot nude figure the
man who had commissioned the work
Pierrot said arenium ruler of Florence
was also impressed but he told
Michelangelo that David's nose was too
broad the sculptors stubborn pride now
came to the fore but it was tempered
with common sense taking a handful of
marble dust he climbed up the
scaffolding and pretended to chisel the
nose he then let the dust forced the
grounds solder Eenie declared that the
nose was now much better
[Music]
in 1503 a new pope julius ii was elected
in rome julius had great artistic
ambitions and he knew who he wanted to
spearhead the many projects he had in
minds and this of course was is elysee
greatest sculptor Michelangelo
Michelangelo had the skills needed to do
justice to the great theocratic works
that the Pope envisions julius knocked
down the unstable 5th century basilica
of st. peter's in the vatican and began
rebuilding the church on a much grander
scale the centerpiece was to be his own
tomb which would be designed and carved
by michelangelo this massive project was
intended to show the greatness of julius
as both the pope and also as a patron of
the arts it was to be three stories high
and covered in life-size sculptures the
sculptor spent the first eight months
just quarrying the marble needed for the
project it would prove to be his most
frustrating project one on which he
would work on and off for the next forty
years in the end they finished tomb was
smaller than plans that still vast only
three of the statues were by
Michelangelo the large bearded Moses and
the biblical characters of Rachel and
Leah and instead of being placed in some
Peters it was put in the much less grand
Church of San Pietro four years into the
tomb project pope julius set his sights
on the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel in
the Vatican the ceiling was painted with
a pattern of gold stars but the Pope
envisioned something far grander even
though Michelangelo was known as a
sculptor and not a painter the Pope
chose him to do the work the great
sculptor had not worked on a fresco
since his days as an apprentice back in
Florence but back in the day when the
Pope chose you for a job you did it but
that did not mean that you have to do it
willingly
Michelangelo considered himself to be a
slave to the whims of the Pope he wrote
about the painting project this is not
my profession I am wasting my time and
all for nothing may God help me it was a
massive job the chapel ceiling covered a
curved surface of about 5,600 square
feet that's 507 square meters in
addition the ceiling has an uneven
surface and it was 60 feet above the
chapels floor the pope Commission's the
artist to fill this canvas with scenes
from the Old Testaments Michelangelo
planned out nine scenes taken from the
book of Genesis the centerpiece would be
the Creation of Adam four for pain
taking years Michelangelo worked on the
ceiling it was back-breaking work the
figures were designed to be seen from
the floor but the artist had to paint
high up on the scaffolding lying on its
back according to his official
biographer Conde V he worked on his own
applying the plaster mixing the colors
and doing all the painting the results
they were breathtaking the use of
perspective and the dramatic rendition
of the figures were admired by everyone
who saw them having triumphantly
completed the Sistine Chapel project
Michelangelo
returned to his work on the tomb of
Julius when Pope Julius died in 1513 the
urgency went out of the project in 1517
the new Pope Leo the tenth asked
Michelangelo to design a new facade for
the Church of San Lorenzo in Florence
though he had no experience as an
architect the sculptor was confident
that he could do a good job he threw
himself into the project buying a piece
of land near the church in order to work
on his facade but then in 15-20 the
project was put on hold and then
cancelled altogether
Michelangelo he was furious he had
invested himself fully both physically
and financially into the project partly
to placate him Pope gave him a
replacement project the Medici tombs to
be created in remembrance of two members
of the family who had died prematurely
Michelangelo began work on the Medici
Chapel in 1519 - which was added a
library a few years later both buildings
took years to complete and are stunning
designs
[Music]
the artist was now at the height of his
creative powers but crisis was just
around the corner in 1527 armies from
France and the Holy Roman Empire invaded
Italy Rome was looted and burnt by now
there is yet another Pope Clement the
seventh and he sided with the Holy Roman
Empire when it besieged Florence a loyal
Florentine Michelangelo returned home to
defend his city he set to work designing
new fortifications to help protect the
city but his efforts they were in vain
after a long struggle the city fell with
many people being killed
Michelangelo he went into hiding
concealing himself in a tiny crypt under
the altar of the Medici Chapel in San
Lorenzo there he States until news came
through that the Pope had no animosity
against him
[Music]
Michelangelo spent his latter years
writing poetry and continuing to work
for the Pope's in Rome one of his most
famous poems describes how uncomfortable
he was when painting the Sistine Chapel
ceiling vents almost double with paint
splashing on his face as he aged he
wrote more poems of a religious nature
throughout the reign of several popes he
held the position of chief architects of
San Peter's meanwhile he worked on
carvings that were variations of the
work that had first propelled him to
fame the Pieta
it was while working on one of his
Peters on February the 12th 1560 for
that he began to feel feverish he took
to his bed and despite the efforts of
his doctors he died six days later his
dying wish was to have his body returned
to Florence the city that he loved so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic s-- if you did there's a
couple of things you could do right now
one is hit that like button below also
if you want more stuff like this we put
out brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]